[Aplausos]
ah
eres tímida o algún día lo fuiste
yo fui una de ellos en los niños es
normal que sean tímidos ya que aún no
están desarrollando la capacidad y que
tienen miedo de expresarse al mundo
yo soy valera serrano y soy tímida por
eso estoy aquí
mi mamá siempre me decía ser tímido no
te lleva nada eso me hizo reflexionar y
por eso estoy aquí para contar mi
experiencia
hace un tiempo yo era muy tímida un día
tal y corriente me eligieron para
cholita cuenca ni en mi escuela yo no
quería porque me daba mucha vergüenza
participar pero con el apoyo de mis
amigas y de mi tutora lo puede lograr y
lo acepte al día siguiente y ahora la
presentación yo tenía mucho mucha
vergüenza después el jurado ya tenía los
resultados en la mano y estaba muy
nerviosa pero al final de todo resulte
ganadora yo no podía creerlo pero sí con
él porque no me imaginé la posibilidad
que hubiera perdido si no participaba y
gracias a eso lo puede superar
hoy en día 13 de cada 100 personas son
tímidas la investigadora caten américas
en el instituto nacional de salud mental
dice que los adolescentes son los que
más sufren y mides según la revista bbc
dice que en japón el 60% de la población
son tímidos
el investigador gos en 1890 define la
timidez como una forma de ansiedad
social así como de ansiedad de audiencia
y vergüenza hasta algunos famosos son
como
el científico charles rabín la gran
escritora agatha christie y el actor
víctor days ya que en alguna etapa de su
vida fueron tibios hasta uno de ellos
como tics por they llegó a vomitar antes
de salir al escenario y que hoy en día
alcanzaron la fama
podemos decir que unas de las
consecuencias de ser tímido es de que
algunos padres están sobre protección a
sus hijos y no les dejan que aprendan
les voy a contar un ejemplo y un día
quería comprar un helado y le dije a mi
mamá si me acompañaba pero ella me dijo
no andamos a comprar yo le rogaba y le
rogaba pero que me acompañe pero ella me
dijo si no vas a comprar el helado nos
vamos yo perdí la oportunidad de comprar
en el lado y saben que fue lo peor desde
que se veía muy rico
pero algunos padres así lo contaron y no
nos dejan superar nuestros miedos
yo para superar mi timidez me dije estas
frases que no son nuevas pero me
sirvieron yo si puedo yo soy capaz y lo
voy a lograr tenga siempre estas frases
en su mente y lo van a superar y nunca
nunca en su vida se den por vencidos
les invito a que no sean tímidos eso
podemos superar no ser tímido no está
mal pero la timidez te puede quitar
oportunidades muchas gracias
y